fa siro pévèle il est avocat au barreau
de milan et paris
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france votre réaction
tout d'abord aux annonces de deux épées
compter ce que seront confinement il est
surprenant
bah écoutez suppléments on est toujours
le même débat le doubs vont privilégier
la santé au éventuellement nous devons
privilégier l'économie le commerce etc
etc
disons que le 80 % des italiens
après le décret des lois 18 décembre
2020 numéro 172 ils ont quand même donné
disons faubert a les décisions du
conseil des ministres alors tout d'abord
permettez-moi d c'est une petite précise
à sion c'est presque la première fois
qu'ils nous voyons à 2t un décret des
lois
je parle bien sûr du baigneur de coheed
et pas d'un décret du premier ministre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça d'un point
de vue législatif
ça veut dire que la décision prix
briques et des grès de noël n'est pas
une décision unilatérale donc qui
appartient au premier ministre mais une
décision collégiale c'est à dire une
décision pris vendredi soir 18 décembre
par le conseil des ministres donc disons
une décision presque et politique qui
essayait comme md rassembler la majorité
est aussi comme on dit allez vas-y
politiques qui sont à l'opposé les
commandes mais la question est comment
la population accueille justement cette
ces annonces l'opinion publique et la
population comme elle accueille
l'annoncent jégou dit on tout vérité
nous ne sommes pas comment dire a
surpris pourquoi parce que il faut
bien étudié le décret leur éclat ont
fait qu'est ce qu'ils prévoient ils
prévoient qui nous laisse ton et quand
j'ai dit nous j'ai dit l'italie
l'altière territoire de la république
italienne
donc nous restons zone rouge pour les
jours du 24 25 26 27 31 décembre et puis
encore le 1er janvier
le 2 janvier le toit samedi le 5 janvier
et le 6 janvier vous savez qu est il y
avait déjà eu un degré qui avait partagé
l'italie en plusieurs zones jeu orange
rouge donc les italiens si vous voulez
il était déjà habitué à ce type de
répartition du territoire de la
république italienne
la quelle est la différence et la
réaction d'orgueil des italiens on est
tous en zone rouge
pendant les vacances de noël donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être tous on
songe savait dire le quai nous ne
pouvons pas bouger entre les régions ça
veut dire que tous les commerces ils
sont fermés
ça veut dire que nous pouvons faire des
activités sportives seulement aux côtés
de la maison ou des activités sportives
individuelles la seule dérogation par
rapport à cette interdiction
je dirais presque globable et la
possibilité d pouvoir aller visiter des
amis ou des parents qui sont dans la
région
mais attention avec des limites maximum
de personnes syndiquées moi et mon fils
on pénètre dans la voiture pour aller
voir
nonna mais peuples des deux personnes
s'ils sont majeurs d'âge cette décision
n'a été prise à quelques encablures de
fête de noël ce qu'il ya là un risque de
voir des de la contestation des
manifestations contre ces nouvelles
restrictions puisque ça avait déjà été
le cas en italie
oui oui alors il y a bien sûr toujours
des gouver station parce que comme je
vous disais au début il y a quand même 1
80% de la population italienne qui
pensent que nonobstant les restrictions
il faut quand même donner privilège à la
santé mais la mathématique qu'elle n'est
pas une opinion d'encre est le vent
poussant de la population italienne qui
n'est pas contente j'ai dirais plutôt
les entrepreneurs les titulaires des
bars des restaurants des boutiques mille
attentions
toujours vendredi soir
le 18 décembre le premier ministre
giussepe est content quand il a
manifesté et de glaner donc qu'est
l'italie rentrée 11 ans le rouge pendant
les vacances de noël donc du 21 décembre
au 6 janvier
et puis une petite dérogation en zone
orange le 28 29 et 30 décembre et plus
encore
nos quatre jamier il a aussi annoncé une
montant des 645 millions d'euros à titre
des dédommagements
tous les entrepreneurs qui font
justement une activité des bals des
restaurations était donc ils sont
obligés dé continuer à ne pas travailler
et donc restés fermés pendant les vagues
atteint donc on va voir quelle sera la
réaction d'un point de vue pratique à
partir du 7 janvier
c'est à dire les landes les plus jeunes
entrepreneurs qui ont été obligés de
rester fermés vont taper la veuve du
gouvernement les caisses de l'état et
demander le dédommagement
alors assez voilà on verra vraiment
quelle est la réaction mais c'est ainsi
repérer les gens paient que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de milan et paris